[Musique]
oui il arrête tu me fais rire mieux il
est bien vivante le mal
quiconque la dernière vidéo qu'on a fini
tu parlais de les mines motoneige et que
tout le monde voulait tuer après en
vidéo que vous en bas du cou mais là je
me suis renseigné j'ai pris des cours
d'histoire et je sais qui c'est qui
c'est le guitariste au
gardien
c est trop cool via les troyens type
flip mais voilà donc où on va vous faire
suivre ça comme on peut
certains estiment être intéressant c'est
le coeur du capital on va tomber plus
amr secret
chuck est aussi le petit shorty
[Musique]
eh bien partout et notre culture bravo
grève merci à vous et accrochez vous
balader
[Musique]
surtout on est avec aux résultats qu'ils
aient ou comment tu vas
on est bien
aurait on s'est rencontrés nous aurait
fait dire à combien il ya trois ans il
faut que vous alliez absolument suivre
aurélie sur ces réseaux sur instagram
c'est à plusieurs comptes
et mes coups de gueule
voyez vous
dans le voyage cemac loterie pas j'adore
le nom
ouais je pouvais les petits liens aller
jeter un coup d'oeil parce que
franchement owen lui elle fait un boulot
de quetta merci aux rennais
baptiste comment tu fais ça j'aime
agissions avec la succion
si sûr c'est incroyable
c'est bien qu'ils vendent pas de tableau
est-ce que c'est métal les clubs c'est
donc on met pas qu'est ce qu'on est bien
c'est quand même un petit paradis seul
geste il fait une cagnotte est
absolument incroyable
[Musique]
on
on va se liquéfier et
[Musique]
shalom
et pas d'agacer la cena
[Musique]
ce geste a récupéré ckoi s'appellera
médiator le mec qui sait même pas que ça
s'appelle à médiator c'est médiator qui
regroupe
tout ça parce qu'ils sont brésiliens
comme toi et loup mais comment tu peux
lire tu peux le dire en rien
[Musique]
tu as réussi à l'avoir signée par
sepultura et hitomi quoi il convient
titre uc orléans euros et c est le vide
dans ces poules devrait la regarder ma
casquette il a fait meilleure casquette
si ça ne te jure c'est vrai mais bientôt
sa casquette recevoir mon pote a encore
la casquette du roi tibétain une [ __ ]
dédicace de sepultura
[Musique]
alors là c'est atelier atelier quale les
ateliers fait moi et ateliers tatouages
ont fait un petit tuto ensuite on
revient poser le brumisateur on va le
faire un peu en mode tuto tuto tu vois
tu t'obstines d'accord et nous salue les
loulous alors regarder enfin petit atout
aujourd'hui alors tu poses les petites à
tous les doudous tu viens mettre le
petit brumisateur volvic et ensuite tu
as puis doucement au petit loulou et on
se dise pasqua et ola anglais mais ça
veut pas pourquoi parce que tu as des
watts tu t'es pas épilée bongo alors on
va recommencer alors les petits loulous
au fatah tout on poste de tatous on
prend le brumisateur chic chic chic chic
chic chic petit tuto installé copains
regarder olala ça m'étonne qu'il
qu'est-ce que tu t'en fous je sois droit
je ne comprends pas on est dans un
festival de métal ont reposé une
connerie son ton bras et tu veux que ce
soit droit ça n'a aucun sens alors les
chéris oppose le petit à tourner en
afrique un petit brumisateur c'est joli
c'est mignon attention aux machinations
niva et copains 1-2-3 ohlala allez les
petits toutous les petits chéris
instagram heures on y va en place olala
s'est vu voilà
j'ai vu que c'est pour la blague
lâche le
marché
permettrait
non mais je jouais pas ça non plus comme
meetic ou quoi
prochaine acheter quoi les jt des
maquettes sont trop belles chez moi et
c'est la sédition hellfest outils pas
batteur
je suis en train de faire c'est bien
[Musique]
tu as une semaine d'avant ce t'as fait
de la merde comment tu sens le conseil
la semaine prochaine très bien je vais
tout donner sur scène exactement j'ai
rappelé au vent j'ai hâte de toi tu as
trouvé la mort
julia c'est joli à julien toulougiens
albos six ans à las vegas la cdu
s'est super bien
depuis quand même c'est pas le jury
ouest reste mais pour voir ce qu on
arrête du coup il fait de le couple
impérial de la tête aurait dû compter
sans doute vous avez votre je vais je
trouve que ça chante pas assez
sec tout à l'heure ils ont envie ils ont
mis bonnes joues vie en musique
hier soir il
met son veto à talons de la transe
changez tout fout le camp ça ça accroche
du conte vie des gens les savent plus
qui vont écouter
quelqu'un mais 80 et stany son calme
comme des agneaux mais pour boire de la
bière la nuit si vous ne
respectez vous bordel un pass vip sort
douloureux en fait l'ailé et déteste les
toilettes ne peut pas chez hugh orde
chez lui et il a fait vos toilettes
sèches et il a trouvé ça génial at il
n'y a pas d'odeur il n'y a pas d'odeur
kaka c'est presque comme à la maison ou
du tout mais on fait tout pour un mot si
on est là 2,9 me ailleurs que chez moi
et là ça m'a presque pas d'erreur il
peut retourner non mais c'est un délire
je te dis il ya des gens des fois ils se
retiennent pendant deux jours les gens
peuvent plus le troisième ils viennent
et en fait dès qu'ils sortent soit mais
ce qui provient
vous êtes des initiés pendant que vous
êtes des génies félicitations comment
s'appelle la boîte merci les gants 12e
et vous êtes basé dans la drogue ces
salles on n'est pas dans la drôme à
saint dizier tout en musique sur
internet et humain direct cerner les
premiers sur la liste eh ben
félicitations envoie du lourd
[Musique]
oh
nick et tu vois quoi s'est trouvée tubes
à quoi tu veux quoi tu vois quoi toi ta
soeur comme tout les ans toi tu vois
quoi forcément un
bon pastis je te prête ma sortie
une bière
gagnol mais toi qu'est la gnôle j'aime
pas au parc c'est pour ça que j'ai en
moi tu vois quoi toi une bière à une
suce tony
ouais c'est pas si tu te les versions
qu'il faut avoir
cette année le premier week end des
fesses c'était super cool on revient le
deuxième week-end et où est ce qu'on va
pour consulter attendant histoire de se
reposer entre deux week-ends des fêtes
et dans les ici on va à vegas parce
qu'elle est gas on peut se reposer et
comme ça c'est très cool voilà allez
bisous à tout le monde et on se retrouve
pour le deuxième week end du hellfest
très rapidement le temps de faire le
trajet retour et un petit avion est fait
bach cool
[Musique]